[Música]
venho aqui contar a história de uma
senhora que sonhava tinha uma
expectativa e queria muito ter uma filha
o sonho dela ter uma filha
comecei então a escrever o livro
intitulado abraçando o mundo e fui então
até a cidade da dança sebastiana
entrevistá lá e perguntar o que foi a
vida dela e ela disse hora
meu grande sonho era ter uma filha
eu casei fui morar com meu marido na
zona rural
fui atrás do meu sonho que ela tem uma
filha
entretanto do outro lado se o italino o
marido da dona sebastiana cuidar aqui
com era um sonho dele e ele disse que
era ter o filho
eu perguntei porque toda sebastiana
gostaria de ter uma filha a chamar de
minha menininha o seu estaleiro porque
gostaria de ter um homem que mora na
área rural
nós temos que plantar e nós temos que
colher a dona sebastiana então partiu em
busca de um objetivo é grave dor pela
primeira vez e teve então a primeira
gestação naquela expectativa de que
fosse a sua filha a dona maria a
parteira com ele a criança dos braços
sai do quarto leva terça já lhe disse
não sei que o homem toma que o filho é
teu e cesar lino é homem e é gostoso ver
os seus amigos vibrar porque nós
precisamos vibrar quando nós conseguimos
alcançar algo nós temos que vibrar
quando nós conseguimos realizar aquilo
que nós desejamos aquilo que nós mesmos
e eu perguntei pro seu talento está
feliz e evitar o tom é um homem e vai
trabalhar na roça vai tomar sol ana
elisa ela tô é meu filho a meu filho eu
estou feliz mas não é sua filha não é
paixão vão trafegar pela segunda vez e
ajudou na expectativa ela dizia
este responsável porque não tinha
conseguido alcançar o seu sonho era
pessoa menina e ela sentia culpada
porque não havia feito nada e pela
começou a dar a volta na casa no sentido
anti-horário começou a atravessar o rio
que saia começou então saltar cobras
tudo isso pra que essa região para que
tivesse a tão sonhada menina a dona
maria novamente o parto retira a criança
leva até a sala e despachou o italiano é
o filho você queria toma que o filho é
teu salino vibrava e tem que vir pra eu
aprendi dizendo que nós temos que vibrar
pela dona sebastiana tá feliz na china
para o produtor o meu filho e você vai
fazer uma grávida de novo eu aprendi
para a dança bastiana e nós temos que
resistir não desistir diante da primeira
ou segunda tentativa latas e baixou de
grafitou pela terceira vez e novamente
ela se empenhou suas coisas absurdas até
mesmo tirar leite da vaca às 4 horas da
manhã que ajudaria ser do sexo feminino
o mais gostoso é que ela perguntava para
as amigas e agora quer que haja um vazio
vai ser mulher
há muita redonda' da outras diziam não
vai ser um time muito forte aguda
as pessoas são assim alguns estão com a
gente
outros não outros não é normal até um
debate tão preparada para sua terceira
gestação chega dona maria retira a
criança chega no próximo dos seus alunos
é um homem que você queria te toma que o
filho é teu
aquele silêncio painel na sala eu
perguntei horas porque não gritar seu
nível
ele disse olha a criança nos braços não
serve para o que eu quero eu perguntei
'e aí consentimento
embora nós aberto disse porque a gente
faz parte o que não serve
eu parei pensei o trânsito aqui não
serve a gente joga fora
eu tenho comigo aquilo que a nossa gente
faz o que
joga participo gente aqui que não é
fácil e jada joga fora a quinta o sonho
de jogar fora quando diz que você não
consegue jogar fora não ouçam português
que você não sabe que você não presta
não ouça o dia que você não é capaz não
ouça mais os já está falando de mim o
que eu fiz eu fui pra roça eu vou
trabalhar para mostrar que é competente
que eu podia fazer eu plantava e colhia
ainda assim não era útil quando se vai
ser disso e em tião eu tenho que mudar
eu quero ser advogado então vamos para a
cidade vamos estudar
fomos pra cidade hora chegando na cidade
coisa maravilhosa outras pessoas outros
pensamentos vamos à escola também é
baixa chegava a junta diretora e ela
disse
essa lei já da minha escola estuda mais
o que ser advogado que eu queria te tudo
porque é algo público é denominado como
algo provisório vinha escola a gente ama
e eu acreditei sempre debaixo do pé de
árvore começou a arriscar o chão começou
a escrever como eu próprio como o
próprio lapso adaptado de um pedaço de
madeira
ele tudo fez sentido tv eu conseguir
construir aquilo que eu tinha com a
família
olhei para o pé de árvore e perguntei
você aceita ser a minha professora
evitou e quando vetou o projeto foi isso
assim não aceitassem sua professora não
pode o pediatra e professora para ser
feliz vale tudo
durante três anos com ele eu fiquei
demais do jardim onde eu aprendi a
escrever pela primeira vez com os pés o
meu nome
logo em seguida pedir escrever o nome da
dona sebastiana
três anos depois voltamos à escola o
força policial eu comecei a estudar
ainda contra a vontade da diretora
perdeu três anos e paixão
vocês terão justificam suas próprias
conclusões mais à frente se eu perdi uns
eu ganhei o nosso tempo ela tem muito a
deus eu tive que fazer
desde o que queremos não sabe o que eu
queria eu queria fazer a diferença eu
queria ser advogado
quando todos pensavam ser impossível
comecei a estudar filho pré 1º ciclo até
a 8ª série
cheguei em casa lembrando de seus
aliados não for meio aí weiwei favor meu
filho e olhei pra passar nem pra ele aí
que tem oitavas a beleza não tem mais o
carinho que você estudar atabaque ué mas
ela claro tudo meu filho sabe o que
aconteceu hoje foi 8ª série ela é e nem
você for para intervenções que aconteceu
mais por sinal todos não é mas se poupou
e o prefeito vai levar às crianças
pobres para ajudá la em água cervejas
sei te dou criança pobre só da mega sena
ganhas presidente e quem vai me levar o
banheiro porque eu não sabia mexer no
cabelo
nós sabemos que vários meus dentes não
sabia trocar de roupa eu não conseguir
fazer isso eu fiquei com vergonha eo
medo que a minha mãe fosse comigo ela
não você vai treinar quando a gente
realmente tem que ter disciplina
a gente tem que ver se ela me fez
pênalti durante uma semana
fica assim o banheiro era semana você
não vai à escola
você vai ficar sem ir ao banheiro
durante o tempo necessário para que você
possa viajar para águas vermelhas
o ônibus sai meio dia e toda a meia
noite
você vai treinar ficar esse período aí
eu ganhei eu treinei durante uma semana
ficará até meia noite
no domingo à noite minha mãe chegou
disse paixão sessão meia noite 40 pode o
banheiro que está demorando tanto no
banheiro de sua mãe
vai que o ônibus quebra é melhor pra mim
é desgraça aconteça eu fui ao banheiro
por volta da meia noite pro dia sic rui
prado vermelhas destaque matemática
destaque que física estava particular
ganhava dinheiro e levava pra minha mãe
e pregava pra ela um pouco do dinheiro
mãe e sei que a senhora ela dizia você
vai conseguir tudo meu filho e pegava o
meu pai mas é um pouco do dinheiro do
senhor e ele disse você é de outra
tentativa de salvar a 2011
já se foi as pessoas em águas vermelhas
pediram para que eu ficasse no final de
semana na cidade não poderia ficar o
final de semana porque o corpo que eu ia
ficar sem banho de média na sexta até
meia-noite na segunda e meus colegas que
tinham fica fica filha não posso porque
tinham eu tenho que ver minha mãe que eu
ninguém vê norminha noite não amanhã eu
volto a dizê a água é minha eu não me
trancar na sala de aula quando eles
abriram a porta o da demora
fiquei uma semana o final da semana
assim o banheiro não porque quando foi
lançado por meio dia eu entrei para o
banheiro foi assim deus por que me dar
essa tarefa tão difícil algo tão simples
e tão disse meu filho já muito sei que
pra dizer todo santo ajuda levante que
as pernas e tira sua causa
levantei minha calça a casa caiu pra
vencer todo santo ajuda a desgraça foi
depois para terminar e não fala o santos
vem participar levantar não mas eu
consegui ir no dia seguinte eu fui
embora taiobeiras porque eu já sabia
vestir a roupa e ao banheiro sozinho
lavar passar cozinhar pentear o cabelo
20 roupa eu fazia tudo e eu fui 71
beiras na expectativa de chegar até
montes claros
fui dando aula até cheguei montes claros
e foi agraciado por uma empresa que
demonstrado que resolveu apostar na
expectativa de ser advogado hora
foram tempos difíceis quando me lembro
que as pessoas diziam que eu não ia
conseguir
mas quando entrei na universidade pela
primeira vez que eu voltei pra besaw e
que eu vi minha foto estampada na parede
do comércio do meu pai que lhe dizia com
orgulho esse é meu filho eu queria fazer
algo por eles
foi isso que me motiva e é isso que nós
buscamos é isso que nós vamos conquistar
algo que os motivos para não desistir
porque o bastardo soutê dificuldades vão
aparecer pessoas para não apoiar também
mas o que importa é estar aqui dentro de
você
conseguir passar com a dona sebastiana
alguns bons anos realizará funções dela
é a música que ela mais amava ea shows
com ela
vivi muito tempo com a torcida baiana
mas já perdi
vi muito tempo com seu talento também eu
perdi então pouco se mexeu não peguei
dois filhos maravilhosos e que eu estou
tentando instalar lo como é o teu pai
seus braços mas o pai que apoia um pai
que nunca dizia que não aceitava do
jeito que eles são
jamais gostaria que o vídeo meu filho
que não gostasse não aceitasse o pai que
eles têm até hoje teve o prazer de
sempre receber ser recebido com muito
carinho e com um abraço afetuoso sempre
que chego em casa e deixado a escola dos
carros da escola dar banho trocar de
roupa coisas inimagináveis enquanto
criança onde faço como pai eu consegui
eu pensei o que eu gostaria era de
abraçar o mundo e hoje eu digo a ele
através do tex que poderá ser traduzido
essa fala pra vários países
eu vou conseguir passar 1.5 a minhas
limitações com as minhas dificuldades eu
conseguir me realizar realizar os meus
sonhos
a presença de vocês o brasil não quer
muito obrigada